I'm going to convert this equation into slope-intercept form. So first I'm going
to add 2x to both sides, because I want to isolate y. I get negative 3y equals 6
plus 2x and I can rewrite this side by switching the terms around. Then I
divivde each term by negative 3 to get 1y is equal to negative 2 3rds x minus 2.
Notice, I have one negative sign here, and one negative sign here, so both of
these terms need to be negative. Alright, now, I'm ready to graph. I know my y
intercept is at negative 2, so I go two units down on the y-axis. I know my
slope is negative 2 3rd. I'm going to put the negative sign with the 2, which
means I move down two units and right three units. If I move down two units and
right three units, I end up here, at this point. This wasn't one of the boxes
down here, so these are out. We could continue moving two units down and three
units right to get other points down in this region. So, I have two points and I
know my line should like this. But how do I get the other points up here? Well,
I assign the negative to the 2. What if I put the negative instead with a 3? In
this case, the 2 would be positive and I would move up two, and the 3 would be
negative, and I would move left three. If I start from my y-intercept and move
two units up and three units left, I end up at this point here. When working
with slope, the positive and negative signs always indicate the directions we
need to move. Two points determine line and the third one is like our insurance,
so if I connect these, I should get a line. So here is the line that represents
our linear equation, pretty cool.